[Music]
[Applause]
kevin millar the mlb network analyst
co-host of intentional talk he won a
world series with the red sox he was at
dodgers stadium last night home run
derby covering the all-star game mlb's
live all-star game coverage from la gets
underway
at uh noon eastern with uh kevin millar
steven nelson co-hosting intentional
talk from dodger stadium at 3 30 today
uh great to talk to you buddy what kind
of memories do you have playing at
dodger stadium
i have a video on my phone from a home
run that i hit off when i say video
voicemail off of chanho park 1999 dodger
stadium my dad got it off of vince
scully's
radio broadcast and he was doing lab
work and to this day i still have it on
my phone out of the 95 different phones
we've gone through i have not
lost that yet so i do have to get down
some kind of tape not to lose that but
it wasn't a walk off
it's just a no just a home run just a
home run in the bullpen as a little kid
from la city junior calls down the
street dad had as skilly as scully goes
that's a high drive and deep left field
and i have to have that forever
that is great
your last couple of years were kershaw's
first couple did you cross paths with
kershaw
never faced kershaw i mean
he throws an invisible slider obviously
the nasty curveball never faced him uh i
talked to sean casey about kershaw he
had faced him he said he's filthy but i
never crossed path wait explain that
what kind of invisible slider
it's like if you watch kershaw pitch
right we know the fastball the big
curveball then he has this little cutter
that he throws and it's that little
cutter that just never gets there it's
down and in the righties uh it's been
his pitch the last seven eight years if
he was just coming up
what kind of pitcher how would he be
viewed if if he threw this wait he's
probably doesn't top out at what 94
maybe 90 95 yeah yeah yeah i don't think
he's not i don't think he's near there i
think he's usually around 92 topping out
he probably pitches at 89 to 90
and then he's got the that little cutter
that that he's put into play
as his velocity has gone down every
pitcher has to figure out
this thing as they get older cece
sabathia was a power pitcher right 98
cutters and sliders and 98 and then as
he got older he had to learn a
two-seamer and a changeup and start
working away off the plate that's one
thing that clayton's done is he's
adjusted to the lack of power with his
fast
football and still able to compete yeah
but i wonder how he would where he would
get drafted let's say he's just coming
up and and
given what we ask of pitchers now
or what we want from pitchers
you got to throw at least 95 to get
their attention now don't you
yeah it's weird danny it's exact the
power it's everything's power right
everything's power power power power uh
and you're right what would he be
and you're looking at a kid you know
coming out of
dallas texas throwing like his i mean
who knows if he's a first round draft
pick because he doesn't have the 95
in today's you know game what about
jeter you know you have the uh
documentary on espn
but you know coming up he was slight
uh didn't have a powerful arm
didn't hit for power you know he ran
but you know he's a first what
top five or top six pick but i wonder
how we would view jeter now coming out
of high school well he's got the size
right he's got height
he's got speed he can play defense so i
still think he's right where he needs to
be is that first round pick and i mean
first round because of his
ability to
the stuff they they judge right i didn't
have a toolbox in that judge i couldn't
run throw hit or field
derek jeter can do it all
but how do you hit a major league
baseball without
like what do you have
like the ability hand-eye coordination
right as a kid
since two in the backyard with your dad
and playing wolf ball everybody has the
ability it's like a hockey player i mean
that what they do on the ice you and i
get
down the ice and slaps the you know the
stuff it's the hand-eye coordination
that's what a baseball player has and
that's one thing i can do is put a bat
you know i mean a ball to the bat
uh and that was something you know but
as far as running the 60 yard dash
seven six seven seven
uh throwing arm is probably a 20
you know defensively they're going to
put you right there in the average thing
but below average because you can't run
and there's no range so that's why i
always say you know it's nice to see
with your own eyes
but that sixth tool is somebody's you
know heart dustin pedroia he was a first
rounder
five foot eight five foot nine and then
you look up you know years later he's a
silver slugger he's an mvp jose altuve
that's what makes this game great
you know how many stolen bases you had
in your career
eight seven
six
seven
thank you do you remember all of them
no i remember
i remember five of them probably being i
was the back end that steal the catcher
went to
were you faster than big poppy
no
vic poppy is a better athlete than he
gets credit for he could play basketball
poppy's got quick little feet they
shuffle he's got a shuffle what kind of
run when you're top heavy you probably
missed leg day about six years of his
life
and i was that guy so he was a shuffler
how would you describe the reaction to
pujols last night
pretty awesome i mean i was happy like
miguel cabrera we had him on the show
yesterday uh albert pujol when
commissioner calls cabrera and you're
looking at you know these guys
it's
greatness right there's a lot of latin
players that looked up to these guys
they're their favorite players that's
what the all-star game is about right
it's it's the storyline of stuff albert
poole holds obviously the back end of
his career obviously the last few years
of the vacuum but this guy was top three
right-handers in the game ever
why still maintain when people say mike
trout boy he's going to be one of the
all-time greats i said
a couple of weeks ago
he should aspire to be miguel cabrera
like let's just start there because
miguel cabrera 500 home runs 3 000 hits
i mean he one of the great now he's not
you know as good all around as mike
trout is but you know mike trout's 30
like you start to look at
you know they wanting to be maze and
mantle and aaron and
miguel carrera is where i would probably
start what do you think of that
it's interesting you're right and to be
great you have to be available now mike
trout's been available i'm just using
you know that this thing we put guys as
stars right fernando tatis jr what a
talent good looking you look at him play
and wiring when he's on the field but
pull holtz manny ramirez miguel cabrera
they did this
for 10 plus years at 30 and 100 and 330.
so they're available they have a healthy
baseball body not that anybody wants to
get hurt but there's some guys that just
get hurt and i wonder what the
conversation is going to be in five
years about ohtani
that are they going to be you know they
drafted all pitchers this last draft
like what are they building to something
that is going to actually come to
fruition where they're he's playing in
playoff games
yeah it's a tough thing because that
organization it's almost you need to do
a street sweeper kind of figuring a few
things out they've spent money they
haven't spent money in the right way
yeah something like already moreno and
the angels haven't spent money but some
of the stuff you're like man okay geez
and then the falters down that they had
never you know since the jared weavers
and escobars and you know when the
angels were good but the starting staff
that go into camp and go yeah i've got
three big boys that can match up with
the walker buellers and the clayton
kershaw's if we get to the big dance the
grom and the max surgeries if we get to
the big dance that's the question right
you can have a great regular season
but you got to have two big boys to
match up with anybody else's two big
boys and the story and that's the
postseason right yankees have a
wonderful year going if they get to the
postseason and run into a buzz stall
then the season is kind of like yeah
that's great
they won 110 games congratulations would
you rather see ohtani at the plate or on
the mound
man if you're the opposition if you're
the opposition
yeah i'd rather see him at the plate i
mean on the mound when he's on i mean
the angels do their two their 20-year
anniversary 2002
john lackey and all the boys are there
and ohtani i think struck out 13 at
night and it's an eye-opener for the
guys that maybe don't watch baseball
time they're like wow
what he does on that mound is pretty
special he's big by the way
what um yeah i can't imagine an all-star
game starting out with two guys bigger
than ohtani and aaron judge going one
two against uh i'm telling you yeah
judge is six foot seven 285 pounds of
pure steel ohtani's six foot five
maybe maybe closer to six six but six
five runs well but a big guy yesterday
comes up you know i was trying to learn
a phrase
and i look up i'm like i'm like these
guys are huge danny like you and i are
normal sized dudes these guys are like
wow
well it used to be if you were taller
you had the bigger strike zone and you
know that was always a detriment there
is that still the case with
being taller and having a bigger
everybody's swinging for the fences
anyway so what's it matter if you missed
two as long as you get one
it's crazy it's crazy you can strike out
now 400 times like all right your launch
angle's good you know your exit velocity
was 109. on your 17 great swings this
year but it's a crazy game now it's
different the shifts are different
it's but it's it's fun these players are
good and the game's in a good spot
a good spot if not the yankees versus
the dodgers in the world series then who
astros versus the braves
mets
mets can get buckshow walter i'll tell
you right now mets you know it was it
was cute coming up to the all-star break
because i
i know one thing the mets that dominate
dominating here the braves are just
coming coming coming if they would have
been in second place not that that would
have been in the world but that have
been weird for the meds that have been
weird for buck showalter but i know one
thing buck showalter was the right and
the exact guy for the match the mets i'd
put in that equation
any problem with soto turning down 15
for 440
no not at all i don't have any problem
with that i have a problem with it
getting out there you know who leaks
this stuff how does ken rosenthal get
this story right
and that that's it's it's an
organizational play maybe or it's
someone inside the scene but honestly
god if you and i are doing a deal and i
choose to turn that down and you're the
owner or you're rizzo or how does it get
out yeah
well
you want soto to look bad don't you
that's the point right so now do you
think what subtle can't look bad he's a
great kid i mean he's 23 years old
listen to him speak watch him play the
strike zone the ability if you're paying
guys
well max yours are 40 plus million
dollars
to make 28 to 30 starts if he's gonna
make them all
where's juan
soto he's not 25 million annual value
and that offer is
420 million dollars more
than you made in your entire career
think about that and that's why you and
i are still working
he he made what you made by the all-star
break
clayton makes that purpose i know
i had to get a job 97 minutes after i
was retired i thought yo the mlb network
launch thank god might have been hitting
fungos and sioux falls uh you know
wherever that i don't even know the shoe
falls at south dakota yeah somewhere did
you ever like when you pulled up at
fenway in your car
i
given everybody else in what they were
driving
like did you could could i tell which
one's milar's car
no i was paycheck to paycheck you know i
had the hummer the h2 with the wheels oh
no
and i had the system and i had one five
in the seats and i had the harley and
you know i was a dude i didn't i never
my i'll tell you this my number was
about 85 000. i never spent
180. you know like everybody's got these
what are these things called those
mercedes those those those
you probably have one yeah they look
like
g wagon thank you
i can't spend 212 on a car right i was
always at 67 camaro
i was always in that that scene best car
on the red sox world series team was
who's poppy i mean when you i told the
story last night i i said listen we we
we hosted a little scene for papi at
marucci uh you know and it was pretty
awesome when tory hunter showed up and
our pools there but
it was just the story of him coming to
pick me up in like a honda civic or a
tote of corolla when i was with the blue
jays in 09 he was dressed in a collared
shirt he had no jewelry he you know and
i joke around them and this is how we
talk back then so this isn't a bad thing
i said dog
you're hitting 180 with zero home runs
you know you're dressed like a white boy
you look like me poppy and i said give
me tomorrow i want to be picked up in
the ferrari i need the bling i need the
necklace i need all the watches the
earrings and he goes bro you're right
you're exactly right he came and picked
me up the next day he had the red
ferrari with poppy on the front he had
every accessorized jewelry he's worth
1.5 million on wrist and wrist and he
goes deep in the first inning he looks
at me and gives me the wing but i said
that's you you're big poppy you can't
come dressed like me off the golf course
uh honda civic uh have fun today i know
your coverage starts in uh well you you
guys got to get ready don't you coming
up at
noon we're live at two oh two okay all
right all right yeah hey great i'll go
back to bed all right all right buddy
thank you
hi dude thanks kevin milar mlb network
analyst and uh coverage live all-star
game coverage gets underway at noon
eastern kevin millar and uh intentional
talk from dodger stadium at 3 30 today